man let me tell you something man let me
tell you something look here's the thing
man uh this movie no spoilers no
spoilers this movie is the greatest
comic book movie that has ever been made
right there's never been a better comic
book movie than this and yes I'm
including Avengers in-game Infinity War
all that kind of stuff the only reason
why Avengers endgame and infinity War
were so good is because the last 10
years that we spent building up to it
judging those movies on their own merits
and leaving out the 10-year tenure
Nostalgia this movie is absolutely
better than both of those movies now
having said that the soundtrack was
phenomenal I finally believe soundtracks
is what what make great movies right the
soundtrack was amazing you know what it
reminded me of and anybody who goes to
see this movie if you've seen it will
probably feel the same way it reminded
me of The Intergalactic Visual Album by
Kid Cudi that was on Netflix dude that
thing was amazing I won all kinds of
awards and stuff it was phenomenal this
feels a lot like that like it was great
now having said that right again no
spoilers having said that Miles more
Alice is on Full display in this movie
and Sun Sun miles is amazing in this
film he's phenomenal in this film it is
I'm sorry I'm so excited people it's an
exciting movie man so here's here's the
thing here's his
it kind of it builds off the first one
right it builds up the first one the
idea that miles is like figuring himself
out all that kind of stuff by the time
you get into this one it's like
full-blown miles right but there's a
point where Miles I don't want to use
like a fairy tale kind of nonsensical
thing where like he starts to believe in
himself or whatever it is but like it's
one of these things where like he starts
to step into his own and gain his own
power abilities pushes powers to the
limits it becomes it becomes like it
gets crazy what he's capable of but all
of this like like as cool as miles was
and as fun as miles was
he had nothing on Miguel O'Hara son
Spider-Man 2099 now here's the thing
what I was hoping for when they said
when they when when they made this the
trailer for this one we got the post
credit scene we got Spider-Man 299 what
I was hoping for is they were going to
do Miguel O'Hara right which is to say
give us a version of Spider-Man who's
who's for the most part a dick but at
the same time amazing and that's exactly
what they did Miguel O'Hara man you're
gonna hate him and love him at the same
time but this dude is a horse now having
said that for all the glitz and glamor
that he has right because the point you
saw in the trailer when you do see the
fight between miles and Miguel O'Hara
right like that happens in the movie and
song song that's that's that's that's
what I'm talking about when I talk about
how like miles it's like when miles is
on Full display because the fight
between the two of them the fight
between miles and Spider-Man 2099 no let
me tell you something I'm not going to
tell you something son dude it is it's
it's
not even in hell would you see a
massacre like that like literally Miguel
O'Hara runs up on Miles Morales Smiles
like man son you better come strong boy
man he takes him for a ride on the Pain
Train bro it was it was amazing right it
was amazing it's it's like it's it's and
that's that's the thing there's there's
a point when Miguel pisses off miles man
it's like it's like it's like it's okay
it's the thing I said to to John Lithgow
in that movie Ricochet you didn't beat
him you just pissed him off and now your
[__] is now he's gonna be out for blood
son that's exactly what it is it's
amazing it was just it was it was it was
it was phenomenal right it was it was it
was amazing but here's here's man here's
the thing here's the thing right
there's a Twist in this movie there's a
Twist in this movie and unless you're
looking for it you're never gonna see it
coming and when it hits you're gonna be
like
oh my God like it's that's that's that
was that was everyone's reaction in the
movie theater it was everyone's reaction
to movie theater when that moment hit
then it was just like
holy [__] dude it was it was it was nuts
right it was amazing and then
um man that goes dude
man that ending son dude that ending Sun
not gonna spoil anything but that ending
some man it's gonna leave y'all like
like literally the movie like the movie
ended right now it's just like
no that was so mad I was like I need to
know what happens now that's right
because like you get Beyond spider
versus like the third movie right it's
like like it ends and it's just like but
but but here's but here's here's man man
here's the thing right A lot of people
are kind of curious about the character
the character is spot I'm surprised they
did what they did spot sucks in Marvel
like in Marvel Comics that guy sucks he
hasn't been relevant in years and he
never did anything meaningful or useful
the only useful thing he did was
appearing in the Jessica Jones Comics by
Bendis after Secret Wars when it wasn't
even him that was interesting it was the
guy who like who killed his wife and
then was like a serial killer because he
remembered the incursions on the
collapse of the Multiverse and he knew
that like this wasn't their Universe
because everything was kind of pseudo so
understand it was a whole different
that's a whole different character has
nothing to do with the spot what they
did with him in this movie Son they need
to do that in the comics dude spot in
this movie is amazing dude Jonathan dude
Jonathan was amazing in this movie and
that's dude that's one of the reasons
why I love comic book movies so much
especially when they change things up
because you get these like adjustments
and modifications to characters that
normally don't matter I mean there are
exceptions for example She-Hulk shoe is
useless in the MCU she's recently in the
comics too there's a reason why She-Hulk
Comics get canceled all the time right
girl couldn't hold her own comic to save
her life she's got all this Incredible
strength right if if holding her own
comic up weighed five pounds she still
couldn't do it you know what I mean like
like it's just it's it's that chick
sucks but the thing about spot is like
they modify and they adjust him and he's
awesome and he's amazing so I I
absolutely loved what they did with this
character but this movie Man between the
soundtrack The oh the Easter eggs
through the Easter eggs the cameos all
that kind of stuff dude it's it's
it's the next level man it is it's it's
yeah
it's the best comic book movie that's
ever been made
you need to go see it it's phenomenal
I'm Thomas explain if I tell you this
movie's good
you better believe it thanks for
watching y'all peace